bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt font savoir première question est
ce que cette amende de 25 milliards de
dollars permet à boeing d'échappée
totalement à la justice cette amende
plus les frères puisque dans les 2,5
milliards de dollars
il y a en fait 250 millions d'amande
il y à 500 millions de dédommagement
pour les victimes des deux accidents et
le reste pour dédommager les compagnies
aériennes qui depuis vingt mois prévu
faire voler leurs avions
en fait cet argent va permettre à boeing
probablement de passer au travers d'un
certain nombre de poursuites et de
complications
mais cet argent permet aussi à l'ipad se
dédouaner puisque vous voyez on accuse
boeing dissimulations de tromperies de
complot de fraude de non-respect des
régulateurs et des régulations mais on
oublie de dire que l'iphone a quand même
pas fait son boulot
l'administration de l'aviation civile
américaine qui dit qu'elle a été trompée
mais qui quand même n'a pas effectué son
travail de surveillance avec
suffisamment de précision et
d'acharnement et qui donc a laissé
boeing m en vol un avion qui avait été
fortement transformer et qu'ici à
l'origine c'était un très bon avion
boeing 737 et un best-seller mondial est
un avion qui par ces transformations et
est devenu un avion dont l'aérodynamique
était mauvaise et dont les systèmes d
aide au pilotage était dangereux et dont
la formation des équipages et la
documentation qu'il aurait été fourni
elle n'était absolument pas adapté
manifestement l'accord signé entre
boeing et les procureurs fédéraux
précise que la fraude n'a pas été
organisée à grande échelle ça veut dire
avec le soutien en fait de la direction
a priori ya seulement deux employés de
boeing qui sont directement visés est ce
que c'est quelque chose que vous arrivez
à entendre qu'une telle opération de
mensonges ne soit pas le fait de la
hiérarchie je pense que c'est très
difficile à entendre parce que
finalement on a trouvé deux lampistes
qui sont les deux chefs pilotes
successifs
et deux chaires pilote d'essai
successifs en charge du boeing 737 max
il est évident ils ont une forte
responsabilité mais on sait très bien
que dans les entreprises de cette
dimension là des gens de ce niveau là
car à ce niveau là on fait partie du
board des gens de ce niveau là sans en
contact avec des administrateurs avec
les dirigeants de l'as de l'entreprise
donc il est bien évident que la décision
de faire voler ses avions avec des
modifications mineures qui en principe
devait le rendre sur est une décision
qui a été prise par le board par la
direction de boeing et qui a été
couverte par les deux chefs pilotes en
question qui se sont succédé ont été
tous les deux intéressés dans la
certification de cet avion
mais la direction de boeing évidemment
maintenant à changer mais cette
direction de boeing avait des impératifs
économiques qui étaient considérables
notamment de lutter contre la
concurrence des airbus a320 bien plus
moderne et deuxièmement il ne voulez pas
investir dans un avion nouveau ce
qu'elle à 6 aurait dû faire depuis plus
de 15 ans et en fait boeing a payé il ya
deux ans et paye depuis deux ans avec 20
milliards de dollars de pertes un c'est
énorme et des risques considérables pour
l'entreprise des erreurs qui sont
commises depuis une vingtaine d'années
c'est à dire la nombre dernier à sion du
catalogue
d'ailleurs les conséquences commerciales
pour le constructeur après une telle
déroute les conséquences commerciales
sont d'une part que boeing n'a quasiment
pas livré d'avions cette année encore
2020 dont n'ont livré 130 le rayon
livres et 800 900 mhz et ya ulcos vide
et ils n'en n'ont quasiment pas livrés
l'année précédant qu'ils en livrer 300
il aurait dû en livrer huit cent mille
neuf cent mais surtout ils ont en gros
perdu leur image de marque d'entreprises
majeures et sérieuse le boeing 737 max
est un avion qui est entachée de doute
même si il y à des compagnies aux
etats-unis au brésil au canada etc qui
font des gestes et qui passe de
nouvelles commandes
c'est un avion dont maintenant tous
c'est que c'est un avion ancien et qui a
été mal rafistolé si on peut dire donc
sur ce plan là bas il ya un gros
problème dans son catalogue en plus les
gros appareils en ce moment ne vole pas
cause du coc vide et boeing prend ça en
pleine figure aussi comme airbus c'est
vrai enfin cette année 2020 airbus aura
livré presque 600 avions boeing en alors
revivre et 130 et il va falloir remonter
la pente et remonter la pente avec un
catalogue qui comprend des très gros
avion qui pour l'instant ne vole pas est
des plus petits avions
mais qu'ils sont entachés de doute ça va
être très difficile merci michel polacco
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste en aéronautique merci à vous